Alright guys, are you guys ready for the spooky time?
Because I'm not fucking ready.
Not fucking ready.
Oh god.
Let me close the music.
It's time to close the music chat.
And...
Oh god.
It's too loud.
My dad came back with bubble tea.
So I'm gonna scream bubble tea in my head.
Oh god.
I hate all of you.
I hate this.
Oh god.
Continued story.
Yes.
Oh god.
May the odds ever be in your favor.
Ready for the speedrun.
You're right.
I shouldn't be scared.
I'm gonna finish this in 10 minutes chat.
Ready for the last 10 minutes of this game?
Oh shit.
Is that...
Alright.
Where are you?
Oh shit.
Hey Teddy.
Okay.
Let me fix the settings.
Oh my god.
I hate how this looks.
I need to fix the sensitivity.
Okay.
I'm baby.
Why are louds at so loud?
Oh god.
She seemed so sad and desperate.
You don't think I...
OH!
I'm sorry.
Oh gosh.
I mean...
Okay.
We're just... Okay.
Anyway chat.
We're just starting the game now.
Damn.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Anyway.
Thank you.
Shit.
What do you mean I fell?
What do you mean?
That was like part of the loading screen.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Chat.
Don't be fucking stupid.
That was part of the loading screen guys.
I...
That's not true.
Yeah.
I just loaded into the game guys.
What the fuck do you mean?
I just loaded into the game.
What the fuck?
Don't be stupid chat.
I can't believe I fell there.
That was part of the loading cutscene.
Oh yeah.
I didn't do that.
Yeah.
I didn't die.
She just... Yeah.
I was... No.
No.
That was just the loading screen.
It was like the loading screen.
It was a cutscene chat.
It was a cutscene.
I didn't even control the baby.
Thank you so much for the follow beans.
Thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Oh shit.
I mean...
Ah.
How about Bloodheart?
Okay.
God.
This is one...
This is the last level guys.
This is the second last level.
It was plot.
Yeah.
It was supposed to happen.
God.
Clearly.
You guys have never played this game before.
It's canon.
Exactly.
I need to hydrate before I go in.
Let me...
Get some tears in me first.
Get some tears in me.
Before I cry it all out.
I choked on water.
There's too many tears.
Oh god.
I hate this.
I'm so fucking hate this.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm processing.
Oh god.
What is this?
What is this level?
What is...
It's so dark.
No.
I hate this.
Let me play as kids or babies.
Oh.
This is so dark.
Oh god.
I'm gonna get out of here.
Why are there puzzles?
Wait.
How do I get Teddy out?
I forgot the controls.
How do I get him out?
Teddy.
How do I get Teddy out?
Oh god.
Guys.
How do I get Teddy out?
Was it F?
Teddy.
That's right.
Okay.
Everything is fine.
It's a puzzle.
It's a...
Everything...
Oh god.
I hate this.
Baby slowly walk.
Baby walk.
Oh god.
What is...
I'm getting goosebumps already.
Let me...
Let me turn up the volume just a tiny bit more.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
I'm getting sheer heart attack.
Twenty.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Awww.
I forgot.
I forgot the climbing sound.
I hate it whenever he has to climb.
I hate this.
I hate this sound when he's climbing.
I wanna go back to art.
I wanna draw again.
I wanna draw.
I wanna get back to art.
Oh god.
Oh...
AHHHHH.
I don't wanna open the door.
Don't make me open the door.
Oh.
I just go back here.
Okay.
Oh.
I just go back here.
What happened?
What the fuck?
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
Have a fun art.
Okay.
How do I get up?
Up?
I just want him to...
Oh god.
I hate this.
You got it right.
Thank you.
Oh.
What did I break?
I'm sorry.
What?
Why?
Oh.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry for breaking some...
Hey, string.
I'm so sorry.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
Oh god.
I hate this.
You didn't miss anything.
Felicity!
Thank you so much for the rain.
Oh.
Let me go under the table.
Let me go under the table before I say anything.
I'm gonna get straight Felicity.
Thank you for the rain.
I'm safe under this table.
I am safe.
I gotta be safe when I thank people for raids.
But thank you.
I hope you had a good stream.
Play Warframe.
Okay.
Alright.
I got this.
Baby's strong.
Felicity!
Oh god.
Felicity.
Thank you for the tier one.
For five woods.
I just spent two hours reading this.
Holy shit.
You get some pork nights real quick for Felicity.
I hope you are doing well with your research paper.
I am dying as a...
I'm dying but...
Oh god.
Please.
I got...
Kill...
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Please don't hurt me.
Thank you, Elphaba.
Thank you.
I'm laughing out my pain right now.
I'm so sorry.
Please don't hurt me.
They miss no.
They miss everything.
Please don't hurt me.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
What?
What the fuck?
Where am I?
What happened?
Okay.
Easter egg.
Pain.
Everything.
All I feel is pain.
I don't know what just happened.
Did I open this door?
Please.
Oh.
Did I get fall damage?
What was that?
Give me a walkthrough and take me out of this hell.
It's not this.
Aww.
Why do I have to walk through a licking lint through?
Oh god.
Why did they give me a maze?
Why do I have a maze?
I don't know.
I don't even know what's happening.
I don't even know what's going on.
Oh god.
Did you speed boost Amphida?
Baby crawl?
Baby crawl.
Where can I crack this?
This is where I need them.
Oh god.
I was.
Oh my god.
The real.
monster was me all along.
What the fuck kind of shadow is this?
The real monster was me all along.
The
real monster was me all along.
It's always the shadows.
Do I fall?
Baby fall?
Baby fall.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
Baby obviously has a GoPro.
Oh key?
What is this key bullshit?
Is this holding a use none to throw it?
None to throw it?
What do you mean none to throw it?
What?
None to throw it?
None.
Alright.
None to throw it.
Okay.
Up here?
Is it not?
No it was right click.
What the fuck?
Nice and nice air.
Dude.
Baby snort.
Oh god.
Oh.
I'm so.
Oh god.
I'm so sorry.
I can't see me.
I'm safe.
If I can't see you.
You can't see me.
It's okay.
We don't have to keep playing.
I'm safe.
I'm in my safe space.
Baby hide.
Oh god.
Okay.
I can get a little more in the sleep gap.
Yep.
Here I am.
Open sesame.
Okay.
Baby snort.
Oh god.
Okay.
What's this?
Is this puzzles?
Oh shit.
She's singing.
Why are you singing?
Why is your...
I had very many spells of hypermorphism and anxiety when I was a kid.
And I still can't explain properly.
Oh god.
I hate this.
I want to look at a walk through right now.
You hear that?
No I did not.
Bear.
I didn't even hear that.
Now that you said it.
Why did you have to say shit?
Bear.
Because I didn't hear it.
Why did they want me to climb up?
Oh god.
Please.
I have enough stuff to worry about.
Damn.
Now you're giving me puzzles.
I'm a baby here.
I'm a baby.
What are the tiles?
I'm fucking 200.
You think a baby knows how to do...
Oh god.
Please.
How is a little baby gonna do puzzles exactly?
I was a dumb baby.
I'm a dumb as fuck baby.
Oh wait.
No.
I'm smart.
God.
I'm so fucking smart.
Look at that.
Baby is Gordon Freeman.
You can do puzzles when you're too free.
Oh god.
I don't know what I'm scared of.
I don't know what can I be scared of.
What am I scared of right now?
What is it?
I don't even know what that is.
Why are you scared?
Baby what happened?
Baby what's going on?
Okay.
Time to breathe.
Baby's breathing.
Baby's alive.
Cause he's breathing.
Put
on baby.
Okay.
Will this lead me?
Where are you taking me?
Oh god.
A baby laying as a baby.
I love you.
Please don't leave me.
Okay... I hate this.
I was hitting just about every anxiety trigger I have and this is not okay.
Oh my god Felicity I'm sorry!
I am just as scared if not fucked up as you are right now with this game.
Thank you so much for the follow pumpkin!
Thank you thank you!
I really do appreciate it.
Have a fun heart.
You cute!
Thank you!
Okay... Okay I am in the kitchen.
I am a small... Oh god who's gonna get you please?
Oh god
baby climb.
Does baby have to climb right now?
Or does baby have to... Oh god I have to not climb.
I have to knock this down.
Don't worry baby can do baseball.
Let me in.
I am so sorry.
Why can't I close the door?
I am a sad now.
Okay.
I am okay.
Oh my god I gotta get out.
Baby is okay.
Baby boy they are okay.
Please let me close.
Let me close.
Please let me open this door.
Please let me open.
Excuse me.
Please.
Anyone out there?
Leave...
Let me in.
Oh no!
I am kidding.
I was like, oh shit that was scary.
Wow guys, wasn't that scary guys?
I'm totally playing this game right now.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Wait, what happened to my shelf?
Where did you go?
Oh, what?
What?
Alright, did I run?
Shit, no, do I... where's my shelf?
What the heck happened to it?
Where do I go?
No, wait no.
Hello, you're on It's Not My Morning.
Hello Mello.
I am crying Mello.
What if we climb... oh shit, up.
The answer was in front of us all along.
Why?
Wow chat, wasn't that a great game guys?
I can't believe we beat it.
This was our objective all along.
Wow, we did it.
See here, we're safe here.
We never had to come up.
We did it.
We beat the game.
Wow, holy shit, we... congratulations everyone.
We finished the game.
Dammit.
No need for food.
We have books and a tiny cabinet.
Yep.
We're still good at this video game.
Thanks everyone for coming.
Stupid babies don't starve.
They don't need to eat.
I've never raised a baby before.
I assume they don't need to eat, right?
I mean, we have books and a lamp.
And teddy.
Wait, why can't I bring out teddy?
Teddy.
Oh wait, I need to stand up.
We have books.
Uh, okay.
Books, teddy, and a light.
Babies don't eat.
Okay, alright.
Alright, um.
They only poop exactly.
Babies, that's why babies are fucking useless.
What do we need babies for?
Do teddies have n- oh my god.
What is this?
Oh, is this another easter egg?
How do I get up?
How does baby get up?
Oh god, what is this?
What is this?
Oh my god, baby stop drawing on walls!
What are these drawings, dude?
Okay, not gonna lie, these are really good drawings for a fucking child to draw.
Draw like this.
This is a god fucking- My- the ball squeaks in the background from my dog scared me.
The ball squeeze actually spooked me out.
What the fuck?
Is she okay?
Is her back okay?
She needs to see a doctor.
I'm sorry for opening the door.
I'm so sorry.
I'll never open doors again.
What the fuck was that sound?
What am I afraid of?
What am I supposed to be afraid of?
I don't know!
What am I so sorry afraid of?
I need to open doors again.
I guess not from Minecraft Street.
Squiggly screens, I guess.
Wait, why won't it let me open this?
Oh
god.
Oh god.
Oh god, what is this ambience?
Oh, baby, just one more juice box.
I hate this so much.
I...
Please, I just want to get- please just- just chase me.
Just- just- just- Just take me out already, mister.
Just...
Please.
Oh, I don't know where you are, mister monster.
Just...
I hate this.
Please, no more ambience, please.
Where do I go?
God, don't make me- don't make me go through this.
There's so many bottles!
What the fuck is Baby supposed to do with all these bottles?
Wait, okay, wait, wait, I got this.
Okay.
Alright, watch this.
I'm not gonna knock down anything.
One.
Watch this pro gamer move.
Baby's skinny enough for this.
Oh god.
Oh god, don't you dare fall.
Don't you dare fall!
I think I'm stuck, guys.
No!
I'm fucked up!
I am so sorry!
Ahhh!
Close the door!
Wow!
I'm so sorry!
No!
Guys!
Please!
I don't know how to close this!
I don't know how to close it!
I don't know how I live!
I'm trying to get closer and he just walked away.
He just walked away.
He actually just walked away.
Hey, I'm alive.
Okay.
There's the other door.
Alright, so what we learned today...
What we learned is...
Slow and steady wins the race.
Alright, there's no more bottles.
There's no more bottles.
The cat heard us and there's no bottles.
Cat heard me.
There's no more bottles.
Okay, let me open this.
Let me open you.
Why is there just a chair?
Why is there just a chair right here?
What the fuck?
I'm not going in there.
I'm not going to go in there.
Why is there just a chair there?
Would you like to take a seat, baby?
I still don't want to close the door.
Close the door.
I learned how to close the door.
I learned how to do it.
I did it.
What the fuck?
I didn't see any glass.
Where is the glass?
Where did I break...
Where did I break the glass?
Where?
Please, explain to me.
I...
I'm like slowly walking here.
And they're like, yep, you broke glass.
Like, okay, you know what?
Fuck this.
Oh my god!
How the fuck am I going to pass this?
Excuse me?
This one glass bottle here?
Yeah, but where do I run to?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Just run?
Okay, okay, okay.
No, I got this.
I'm not a fool.
I'm not going to touch you.
Let me in.
Alright.
Oh my god, please.
Where do I go?
Dude, fuck this maze shit.
Nadia, thanks so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Where do I even go?
Not only are they giving me bottles, they...
Is that just a shoe?
Okay.
I was going to be like, not only...
Um...
Dude, I'm a baby.
That's the premise.
I'm a fucking baby trapped in hell.
Like, I don't even know.
Not only do they...
Do they have bottles, I had to hide from a monster, and they had to give me a maze?
Like, what the fuck is...
I'm just a fucking baby.
Come on.
Just give me one.
Not twenty of these things.
Like, I don't know where to go.
Oh, there's a bottle.
You play a baby exploring a dreamlike world evading...
Yo, that's a better explanation than me.
All I said was like, I'm a fucking baby trapped in hell.
I'm scared there's fall damage, so I'm just gonna...
Boop.
Wouldn't it be fucked up if you gave a baby fall damage too?
Open.
Oh, god.
Where's the memory?
Okay, okay, I'm safe in the memory.
I'm safe.
I'm safe in memories.
Memory is safe.
Please.
I swear, if a monster comes here...
How does a baby even end up in...
I don't know.
Baby did a bad thing.
Hurry where?
Do I have to run?
Oh, god.
Oh, no.
It's here.
Okay.
Where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
Here?
Baby run.
Baby fucking run.
Baby, please!
Run faster, baby!
Baby?
Baby.
Oh, god.
Please.
No!
Oh, god.
That was the... Yeah, dude, I don't give a fuck about bear.
You can take him.
Please.
Just take the bear.
I don't care.
Let's just take the bear.
Oh, god.
Oh, no.
I thought you were that online.
You should just let him take the bear.
You stupid baby.
Well, at least we know there's no fall damage.
At least we know.
There's no fall damage.
He has no heart.
Oh, god.
Give me light.
Light.
You are as good as... I'll make a traumatizing game about baby.
Oh, oh.
Baby run.
And he's just looking right.
Get what you want.
No, no.
Baby's found.
Oh, hey, mom.
Hey, there.
Hey, mom.
Mom!
Hey, mom!
Please.
Oh, she's in...
Oh!
God!
No!
Okay, mom's an alcoholic.
Okay.
Alright.
At least we know that.
Mom's an alcoholic.
Mom is an alcoholic.
Please, baby.
Please.
Baby.
Oh!
He's
like, you can't hurt me.
You can't hurt me!
I'm like...
I will not take it.
Oh.
What
mommy says.
Mommy, I'm sorry.
Please.
I'm sorry, mommy.
None of us want that.
Oh, God.
Please.
Please, baby.
You're faster than this.
You made me.
Please.
You're faster.
I'm sorry.
I'm not
kidding you.
What?
Did she just say, I will find you?
Technically,
I was...
I was dying mentally.
I was getting killed in my mind.
It's okay.
We don't need Teddy anymore.
We don't need him.
It's all... It's you and me, chat.
All I need is just chat.
Who the fuck gives a fuck about...
Who gives a... Am I stuck?
Wait.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Oh shit.
No, I'm sorry.
I fucked up.
Wait.
I'm stuck.
I broke the game.
I can't even...
I can't even turn the wheel.
How did... I'm trying.
I didn't... Okay chat, I am trying.
I actually broke the game.
Please.
Oh no.
I can't turn the wheel.
It won't let me turn it.
I actually broke the game.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I can't even...
I can't even... exclamation point.
I actually broke the game.
How do I fuck up that badly?
How do I... How do I fuck up?
I can't.
It won't let me turn it.
Wheels.
My natural... It won't... I can't even...
press escape chat.
I had to... I actually broke the game.
I actually broke the game.
Holy shit.
It won't let me turn the wheel.
Oh god.
Where is... I actually...
Oh my god.
I actually... Chat, if I restart this...
Is it... Oh please don't make me replay this part again.
Oh no.
Please.
Let me turn the wheel.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean anything I say.
I'll save bear.
I'll save the bear.
I love bear.
I love the bear.
I'm so sorry.
Please let me turn the wheel.
No!
Oh no.
It won't let me...
do escape too.
I can't even pull up my options.
Alright.
Game.
I'm so sorry.
I can't even open the chest.
Okay.
At least mom can't find me again.
Alright.
Chat.
Let me... I have to... I have to... I have to...
restart the game.
I can't believe I broke the game.
I... I...
I actually can't believe I broke it during this stage.
What can I not do, chat?
What can I not do?
Can't turn the wheel apparently.
Holy shit.
I just don't know how to turn wheels.
Well, I'll be right back.
I'm gonna... well, I will still be here.
I'm just gonna... I'm just gonna restart the game.
I guess.
I guess I'll just restart the... Oh my god.
I guess I'll just restart the game.
Oh my god, dude.
Where is it gonna take me?
Oh my... I'm so sad.
I swear if it makes me do that level again...
The nightmare being recursive is part of the requirement.
Oh god, I have to go through this.
Oh god, where is this gonna restart me?
Where are you gonna restart me?
Oh!
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Oh, thank god it's here.
Oh, thank god it restarted me here.
Doki's laughing at me.
Doki, Doki.
Oh god.
Thank you.
I'll close the door.
Maybe it's because I didn't close the door.
Holy shit, I was... I was gonna be like, where are you gonna restart me game?
Okay.
Alright, I won't break it this time.
Oh god, I did it.
See, now I can open this chest too.
Now I can open this chest too.
Boom.
Wait, how do I do this?
If I click it really fast, maybe I can do it.
Oh god, is it gonna make me go out?
Is it gonna make me go out?
The F block?
I don't need Teddy.
I have the F block.
I'll just put this on top.
Who needs Teddy when I have blocks?
Okay, that didn't work.
Okay, maybe I do need Teddy.
Wait, no, no.
I don't need Teddy.
I have... okay, I was gonna say... we don't need him!
I lied!
We don't need him!
God, just...
God, why is your arm so bent?
Who needs to... turns out Baby is actually some drunk dude running and hiding from cops.
AKA a monster.
Okay, alright.
Yeah, we have book and lamp.
And that's all.
Okay, I swear, I can just get this lamp and then just put it on... there should be another ending where we leave without Teddy.
Cause I would take that ending.
I would take the ending without Teddy.
Like, fuck him.
Like... If I could get an ending without him, I'll fucking take it.
Oh, God.
Oh, God!
Where do I even go?
Is this... Is this the street?
I hate this.
Oh, God!
So what?
I'm fucking gonna make it such as a bug!
Thank you!
Let's see how that ends.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh my God.
I don't know where to go.
Baby go up?
Where's up?
Where is up?
Where... Where... Where is...
Baby go?
I'm back here.
Puppies?
What if... Oh...
Oh, I get it.
Right?
See,
I don't need Teddy.
I don't need him.
I have his arm.
I have his fucking arm.
Who the fuck needs him?
I don't need him.
No, baby.
Never go down.
Who the fuck needs him?
I have a fucking arm.
That's all I need.
How the hell would anyone figure that out?
I'm back home.
Nothing.
Stop crying, little baby.
You have an arm!
Teddy was the only constant and you needed a friend to solve the last puzzle.
Fuck Teddy, we don't need Teddy.
I only have his arm.
All I need was his arm.
Oh god, it's getting darker.
I don't like that.
I don't like that it's getting darker guys.
Oh god!
Awww.
Hey Teddy.
You need my Teddy back.
Oh god!
Please!
I don't even want him.
I never meant to.
I don't even want Teddy.
What?
Oh shit, hate.
Can I look at her?
Dude, she's a terrible mom.
Like, I don't even want her.
What the fuck?
Let's go into the light.
Hi little one.
Come here.
Did you like your gift?
Oh is that dad?
Hey dad.
Is that acid?
Yes.
Acid?
I'm sorry to hear.
What?
I think it's getting less and less related to this.
Yeah.
Oh!
We did it!
Oh god.
We finished the game!
Holy shit!
We did it!
We beat the game!
I'm so proud.
We did it chat.
We did it together.
We didn't fucking need Teddy.
All we needed was his fucking arm.
I don't have custody now.
Shit.
I like how there's like no music at all.
It's just...
Baby did it.
Baby went up.
Woo!
We did it guys!
All baby had to do was go up.
We spent a whole game carrying all that extra weight when we all needed...
Right, Lesser?
We didn't need shit.
All we needed was fucking arm.
And then you had the option to hug her at the end by the way.
Oh, who gives a fuck about her?
Dude.
Time for nononono... Nonononononononono.
No, Hattage, no.
Holy shit, chat.
Teddy didn't do shit!
He didn't do fucking shit this entire game other than giving me his arm.
That was, like, his only benefits throughout that game!
Oh, he was like, hey, I think, hey, did you hear that?
Oh my, like after like the thing was gone, you'd be like, wow.
Wow, baby.
Did you hear that noise when I didn't hear shit, but he wants me to hear something?
Teddy made you go into the wardrobe.
And he put us in the mess in the store.
But time for lightheartedness wholesome.
Lightheartedness wholesomeness, holy shit.
So we chat.
I can't believe we beat the game.
Another scary game under the belt.
Did that say Batman?
What the fuck?
Wait, did you guys see that?
It said Batman.
What the fuck?
Big Andy.
Okay, some of these names are great.
Big Andy, dude, there's no music.
What the fuck?
Wait, let me put some music on in the background.
While we, instead of like this omnis...
sound.
Let's have some music.
That makes it better.
Makes it even better.
Allegorically since I missed the beginning.
Yeah, we're... ooh.
Some chill song in the background.
Leave it as it is.
This is like Persona 5 music in the background.
While I was like...
Dark Wolf 9.
Someone put their fucking Dark Wolf 9.
Doki Baby got wrinkle and brain out.
Next try wrinkle.
Earn.
Every game I finish, I earn more wrinkles in my brain.
Certainly, I have two wrinkles.
I have finished two games.
But without Teddy, we'll be one forever.
Just to be smoothed out 20 minutes later.
The real Teddy was a wrinkle we made all along.
I honestly did not think the game was gonna... we were gonna...
We were gonna finish this game so quickly.
How long did that take us actually?
Oh shit, wait that took us an hour.
Wait...
That was an hour of gameplay, holy shit.
I felt like... wait sorry I mean 10 minutes.
Sorry, I meant that took me 10 minutes.
Damn.
Like so many Daniels.
Why are we still at the... how long is this credit?
How long is this credit?
Cause we're still... oh now we're at ease.
Okay we made it to the ease guys.
Holy shit it's from 8 to... you know what?
Yeah we don't need to learn about all the Eddies up there.
Do we have like bonus?
Playground in the account... Museum?
What's this museum?
I was thinking that going to all the...
Finally among us the light in the moon.
We need to see every name.
Alright let's look at the museum chat.
I'm there right now.
I like how the Persona 5 music is playing in the background.
Okay what the fuck?
Where the fuck are... what's... is this ghost Teddy?
Is he dead?
Wait did Teddy die?
What?
Wait... wait so his arm is gone and he's dead?
No... take a look around.
Teddy's a ghost now.
Wait Teddy actually died.
What the fuck?
Teddy is your subcon Teddy ghost.
This one's awesome.
The birth of among us...
I just broke...
Okay no.
I should have revived...
Just a case.
Dude Teddy could have been so cute.
Like this is such a cute version of Teddy.
Sorry my dog is like looking at my dad and outside.
Teddy is a sacrifice to peace...
Uh... the... the blonde guy.
Yo what... this is so fucking...
Dude okay I... I hate like... I know this is like textured for 3D.
But this looks so... so...
Oh gosh Doki no.
No Doki.
No.
Come on.
Sorry my dog is...
Harold...
Harold Hydra.
Oh god dude fuck this girl.
Oh so this is the monster.
Is this a co-monster?
I don't know dude fuck this bitch though.
Oh we never saw like his top half until... until the end.
Wait where's the museum?
I wanna go to the... the gallery.
The museum gallery.
Oh here it is.
Here it is.
Show puppy?
I have a lot of photos of my dog in the discord.
I mean...
Oh god.
There's a prologue?
You guys wanna...
Oh should we play the prologue guys?
You guys wanna play the prologue?
Like... we could play it.
Oh shit yeah I'm so fast.
What the fuck?
That's so fast look at that baby.
Alright well we'll play the prologue after we look at the museum.
I drew my nightmare once and I look pretty sick.
It will be in my memories in 70 years of life.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
I'm gonna turn off the music now.
Maybe zoom.
I don't understand why Teddy has to be a goat.
This is a sign choice.
Go on the computer?
Holy shit.
Okay.
Dude, fuck the playground.
When was your birds?
Wait, there were birds in this game?
What the fuck?
Wait, there were birds in the game?
Since when?
What?
What were there birds in the game?
What the fuck?
All I remember was owl.
All I remember was this fuck.
That's all I remember.
Okay, so these are all the artwork of the playground.
What is this?
What was...
Oh, this is like a... the diagram.
Patty...
He's laughing.
He kind of says... okay.
Oh, he was too scared to notice.
Yeah, I didn't see the fucking bird.
This thumbtack was unwrapped in sea brush.
Never let's say we're happy.
The house here is a symbol of the family and home falling apart.
The bloated creature inhabiting it is how the kid sees his mother when she's drinking and full of sorrow.
Awwww.
This is like the designs of the house.
Where's the monsters?
Oh, this is the...
Teddy, where are you?
How am I supposed to learn shit without Teddy here?
Wait, what?
What's this?
Oh, this is the exit.
I was like, what is this?
Where's Teddy?
How am I supposed to learn anything?
There's the monsters.
Oh, God.
What the...
Who's this?
What?
What the fuck?
Wait, what's this here?
What?
We go back.
We grab the airplane.
And he look like...
Wait, did he look like that?
What the...
What?
Yeah, fuck Teddy, dude.
Holy shit!
Okay, wait.
Now this is...
The story of how the game ended was very different in the early days of production.
Back then, Teddy was antagonist of the game.
Oh!
Actually, kind of silly what I drew.
We don't need Teddy this whole time.
The lore is so well thought out.
Yeah, the lore is very interesting.
Um, and an evil entity, a monster disguised as a friendly teddy bear took advantage of this by taking the child into a dangerous adventure far away from home.
Um...
Oh, so okay.
So it was like that.
Oh god, why did they have to give him black eyes?
Like...
The black eyes is so unselfish.
Who's this?
Who the fuck is this guy?
I know these three.
Or two.
Who is he?
I don't remember shit.
Harold?
Harold, who are you?
I remember him.
And her.
Oh god, dude.
Did I hate you?
Holy shit.
Oh god, I don't want to look at her anymore.
You completely missed him.
Yeah, I've never seen him.
Where's mom?
And there's all the plushies.
What are these?
Sleep?
What are you?
There's our very early projections.
There wasn't a sudden decision to cut these.
Oh, they're like...
They're all the cut creatures that were supposed to be in this game.
What?
What's this?
I'm guessing he's a monster in the playground stage, but we never met him because of the gun plays.
Yeah, is that... Oh my god!
What the fuck is...
Excuse me?
What the fuck?
Okay, I'm getting out of here.
What the fuck was that?
Okay, like...
Oh god, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
What's over here?
What?
Alright, Teddy goes top.
Oh, okay.
Wait, okay, look over here.
What are you gonna say?
Ah, my favorite place.
I felt we really connected here, you know?
A bit of a breather between the various bad, nightmarish worlds we went to.
Also, I was able to talk a lot here, as elsewhere the developers were concerned about keeping the tension up.
And didn't want me to sleep.
It's literally me screaming now.
How scary...
Also, I kinda get quiet when scared.
So...
I'm okay and all.
But I liked best the times we had to catch up.
Where's this area?
Can you talk to me?
Originally, the chase for the mom was a MacGuffin.
You did not really find her.
And the monsters used her to lure you further into the dreamlands.
And we struggled for some time to make sense of this story.
Especially the playtesters were confused as the story ended without you seeing your mom again.
How do I even get out of here?
Proceed to see the old ending of Among the Sleep?
Oh shit.
What is the old ending?
Oh, is this where he becomes like an evil guy?
Okay.
Oh god, this is the original ending.
Oh god.
What is this?
Can I move?
Oh, I can move!
Oh, okay, but that's it.
I can't do shit.
Okay, there's Teddy.
There's evil Teddy.
Tastes like sneak fear!
Oh, is he gonna... oh, he's gonna cook me.
Oh, there's... hey, Teddy.
Hey, Teddy.
Teddy.
Where did you go, Teddy?
Where did you go?
Teddy?
Oh, what do I do?
Oh, oh god, Teddy.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
What the fuck?
Hello?
Oh!
Oh god, oh, it's him!
Oh, god!
I hate this!
Bring me back!
I'm so sorry!
Please!
Well, guys...
Well...
Okay, yeah...
Uh, uh...
Uh...
That's it.
Okay, the longer I stare at him, the less scary he gets, not gonna lie.
Uh, you know what he reminds me of?
He reminds me of the... the SpongeBob grandma from the chocolate episode.
Like...
Yeah, you're like...
Yeah, you're like the grandma in the SpongeBob...
Let's see...
Yeah...
The more I look at him, the more I realize...
You know, it's not that scary.
The more I...
Chocolate!
I smell the dreams of lime trees...
And then some chocolate.
But I...
But I'll keep up with this.
This guy...
This guy watched SpongeBob, that's for sure.
He's coming as I am...
And he's singing us a song before he eats us.
Isn't that sweet?
Lime trees, and the sand is there...
Thank you.
You did very well.
I will enjoy it.
Please just eat me, dude.
I'm okay.
Oh, God.
Very thoughtful of him.
Very thoughtful of him for him to sing us a lullaby before he fucking goes home with us.
I'll work just so I can still love it.
Bye-bye.
Sing me a lullaby before you eat me.
Kind of...
Yeah, how do you put...
Did you just chuck us into the can?
But he was like...
He's like, I'm gonna make it...
I'm gonna make it less painful.
I see no point why we would eat a baby unless a baby had some...
I mean...
I mean, you eat baby...
Some people eat baby chickens and baby deer.
It's like saying, why would you eat a baby?
What is...
I mean, early horror games were more on jump scares, right?
Yeah, I like the...
I don't know.
Oh, there's lore here.
It's very interesting.
Alright, let's play the prologue, guys.
How long is the prologue?
I hope it's not super long.
Can I just fall in?
Oh no, I don't die.
How do I get out?
Ooh, fast baby.
You know what?
Oh, this is how you get out.
I was like, how do I get out?
Alright, let's try the prologue, guys.
Um...
Alright.
I'm gonna see how long... I'm gonna look up how long the prologue is, guys, before we play it.
How long it is among the sleep prologue.
Just so... just so I know.
Alright.
Um, complete.
Okay, 15 minutes.
So that's like one hour.
I mean, no, we're gonna speak... so that's like five minutes for me.
If it takes 15 minutes to complete it, it's practically...
five minutes for me.
Easy.
We got this.
Five minute speedrun.
Let's fucking go.
You're probably... yeah, exactly.
Probably clear in five minutes, chat.
Why am I in the fucking... why the fuck did they put the baby in the snow?
Baby, why are you in snow?
Who the fuck left the baby in the snow?
What the fuck?
Oh, god, what?
Teddy?
Where's Teddy?
Oh, it's a prologue.
I haven't had my birthday yet.
I haven't had my birthday.
Cold.
So... so cold.
Who?
Who said that?
That's not me.
Baby can't be.
Baby can't talk.
Oh!
Hey there.
What did I do?
Hello?
Oh, hello?
What the fuck do you want me to do?
I'm gonna leave you.
Oh, wait, I was gonna... I thought I had to open that and leave.
I was gonna...
What?
I thought... I didn't think it was cool.
I thought I was gonna go outside.
I was gonna go leave you.
Alright.
Hey, Renner.
What do you want?
Oh, oh.
Save.
Thank you.
Monsters don't like happiness.
Yeah, fuck happiness, dude.
Dude!
Warm,
good, cold bath.
I haven't seen press the teddy button.
Nothing.
I can't do anything with the teddy button.
Can I open the door?
Oh I can.
I have to go up.
Maybe up.
Why is it dark?
Hello?
Oh!
Wait!
Why are you back?
Can't see me.
We don't need teddy.
Mom can't see me.
I'll just go this way.
Oh gosh.
Step by step, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Have a...
Have a butthurt.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Where the fuck do I...
Is this another maze?
Please.
Not another maze.
Oh!
Lore!
Thank you, LF.
Oh god.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a butthurt.
Thank you so much.
How many plushies do I have?
Okay, but...
Where are these plushies?
Please don't make me try and find them.
Please don't...
Please don't give me a maze.
Do do do.
I'm okay.
Gotta find them.
Smile.
Do do do.
Ah!
Oh, baby.
Hey, mom.
Hey there.
Oh, mom gone.
Please.
Mom gone.
Okay, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
How do I even get up?
Oh, up.
That's how.
That's how I get up.
Wait, how do I get up from here?
Oh, I don't need to get up, right?
Okay.
Ugh.
Excuse me.
Excuse me, county sir.
How do I close a window?
How...
I don't know how to do a lot of things, apparently.
I'm a very dumb baby.
I'm so sorry, man.
I'm so sorry.
I'm very dumb.
I don't know how to close windows.
Wait, can I move chair?
Oh, I can move the chairs.
Look.
I died.
I'm a very dumb.
Oh, shit.
I'm a very dumb baby.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, happiness.
What makes you happy?
Happy, please.
I don't know what makes me happy.
What makes you happy?
See?
Knife?
Okay.
Definitely not the knife.
I don't...
Ball.
Oh, that is not a ball.
Oh, God.
Wait, I fucked up.
I don't think I was supposed to pick that up, guys.
I don't think I was supposed to pick that up.
I caused my own.
I actually caused my own.
I almost fucked myself over.
Okay, so what I learned...
was that I was not that.
What makes you happy?
Oh, maybe?
Does this make me happy?
Okay.
Okay, where the fuck is your shit that makes you happy?
Where are you?
What makes you happy?
Okay, well...
What makes you happy, mister?
Make happy.
I'm trying to figure this shit.
Dude, my brain is so tiny right now.
I don't know what the fuck would make this guy happy.
What makes you happy?
That does not make happy.
Okay.
Okay, but...
What?
Was I supposed to bring the music box?
What makes him happy?
Okay, let me go back.
There has to be some happy things here.
Oh, wait.
The fridge?
Is there happy things in here?
Is there
happy things in here?
Okay, nothing in here looks happy.
What if we turn on the sto- Oh, true!
Okay, no, you cannot turn on the stove.
There is nothing there where I can turn.
Dude, what the fuck makes you happy?
You're not helpful at all, mister.
I don't know what makes you happy.
Does milk make you happy?
Ooh, is it milk?
No, I can't pick it up.
Oh, I can.
Does milk make you happy, mister?
Mister?
Does milk make you happy?
Have some milk.
Okay, I don't think he wants milk.
How the fuck did this person finish this in 15 minutes?
It was not milk.
What makes you happy?
Dude...
What was that?
I'm so sorry.
Oh...
How do I make you happy?
You're fantastic.
I'm doing...
How do you make happy?
I've been stuck here trying to...
Oh shit.
Wait, play?
Let's play make happy.
Play.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, baby.
Thank you so much.
That'll follow.
Oh, shit.
Thank you.
I got play.
Does play make happy?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
It's not playing.
We don't know how to make happy.
I need to think here.
What makes you...
Okay, we're like stuck in this one level.
Because we don't know how the fuck we make happy.
We don't know how to make...
We're gonna be stuck here forever.
We don't know how to make happy.
Oh, God.
Monster.
I'm so sorry.
Let me hide.
Audible.
Someone drew the tier one.
Sixteen months.
Thank you.
It's a great night deal quick for Audible.
Do I have to go back?
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so sorry.
I
don't know how to make happy.
Wait.
Climb up?
Where's happy here?
Happy?
Anything happy here?
Any happy times?
Okay, that's no happy time.
Banana?
Find happy.
What makes happy?
I don't know.
I've been trying to figure out happy for so long.
I'm so...
Please.
Where do I hide?
This
makes me happy.
This makes me happy.
This
makes me happy.
Okay.
Come
on.
I'm so happy.
Remote makes you happy!
Okay!
Remote?
Huh?
Remote makes happy?
Oh!
Remote makes happy!
Thank you!
Are you seeing?
Okay, remote makes happy.
Okay, then where the fuck...
This is a good memory.
Oh!
This is supposed to be a happy place!
What the fuck?
I thought this was supposed to be a happy place!
I like this studio.
That did not make me happy.
That was not happy.
That was not...
What?
What is that?
Oh, that monster went in.
Oh my god, there is Harold!
Hey Harold!
Can, can...
I guess we are not going back there!
Well, I guess we know we are not going back this way.
Can I go here?
Is he gonna move?
Dude...
So what makes happy in kitchen then?
If I do this, will I die?
Oh yeah!
Yeah!
Okay...
What the fuck?
What
the fuck?
Oh my god!
Please!
Wait, I need to go back and figure out how to make happy again.
I am still trying to figure out how to...
I am gonna go back.
I need to figure out how the fuck do we make this guy happy.
Like, what is it?
What could it be?
It has to be something here.
Yeah.
Also, Ginger, thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it.
It has to be something in here then.
What makes you happy?
Oh wait!
Thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you, thank you.
I have some butt hearts.
We are trying to figure out happiness.
The secret to happiness right now.
It was not playing.
I did, I looked at the table.
It wasn't table.
Yo, you still...
What makes you happy, Bear?
Radio!
It's radio!
That's gotta be it.
Radio.
Okay.
How do I get up though?
It's radio!
It has to be radio!
Radio equals music!
It's radio!
No, no.
You got a butt heart.
It's even better.
Cause I can't make a proper heart and it looks like a butt.
I did it!
It was radio all along!
Now where did the bear go?
Oh, there.
Oh, the fox go.
There you go.
It was the fox all along.
I made him happy.
Alright, we go back to the...
We go...
Okay.
All right.
All we need is Teddy, right?
I don't like the squeak in me when you grab it.
Sorry, my dog is growling right now.
You're gonna hear my dog growl.
Hey, mom.
I don't like that.
Sorry.
Please stop making sounds.
Please.
I'm sick.
Where did I go?
Was that just lore?
Did I not have to go here?
Was it just lore?
Do I go outside?
Well, I'm not gonna go outside anymore.
I'm gonna stay here.
I'm not gonna go outside.
What the fuck is that sound?
What?
What is that sound?
Who gives a fuck about the outside?
Not me.
Okay.
I hate this.
I hate it.
Let me in.
Oh my god.
Please let me in.
Harold, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Harold.
I'm so sorry.
Harold, no.
Harold.
Harold, gone.
Bye, Harold.
How do I open this?
Stupid.
Wait.
I think I'm...
I'm back where I started.
Wait, where the fuck did I go?
There's no place to say goodbye before you're leaving.
Well, I finished the game.
I finished it, guys.
Well, look.
I did it.
I don't know where to go.
Oh, up?
Oh!
Up!
Baby, go up.
Wait.
Baby dead.
Baby...
Oh, wait.
Baby no.
Go up!
Apparently, I guess he doesn't know how to do stairs, too.
Thank god.
At least he doesn't know how to do...
Oh, I get it.
That computer room.
Remember that computer room earlier?
But where was the computer room again?
I don't even remember.
I don't...
I'm so lost, guys.
I don't remember where the computer...
Memories!
Happy!
It's okay, baby.
Happy for now.
I just need to go to the computer room again.
I need to remember how to get there.
I think it was like here somewhere.
Yeah, it was like here.
Right?
Yeah.
This must be where Key is, right?
What?
Where did Baby go?
Where did I go?
Where am I?
Did I break the game?
What?
Wait!
Did I break the game?
Excuse me?
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, what?
I think I broke the game.
Where am I?
Damn.
I broke the game.
How did I break the game?
I just climbed up a chair.
All I did was...
I climbed up the chair.
And then I broke the game.
Because I can't climb chairs, too.
Okay.
I don't want to restart it, guys.
It was the wrong chair.
Okay, load from last checkpoint.
Let's see where it takes me.
Okay, happy times.
Woo!
Back in the kitchen.
Back in the kitchen I go.
Alright, lore.
Woo!
Lore.
Back in here we go.
Yeah!
Lore.
Hey, Cryptic.
Oh, god!
I'm so sorry.
Oh!
Harold.
Bye, Harold.
Bye.
Please open the door.
Open the door, lady.
Alright, back.
Alright, let's get on the chair again.
Oh my god, Gumi!
Oh my god, Gumi.
Thank you so much for the host.
I don't...
Gumi!
Gumi, thank you for the host, Gumi!
Were you streaming earlier?
Gumi!
I hope you had a good Gumi Mod Center.
I cried.
Hello, everyone!
Hey, Reaper.
Hello, thank you so much for the follow.
Have a good Bloodheart.
Okay, um...
Okay, where's the key?
Where's the key?
Key, where you at?
Hello, everyone!
From Gumi's stream.
Hello, hello, hello.
You're streaming no game.
Wait, what?
Was Gumi's stream...
Thank you so much for the follow, Hannah.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
She fell asleep!
Thank you so much, Applebutter.
Hello, everyone from Gumi's stream.
I am...
I am trying to...
What was she...
She fell asleep.
Did she pass out?
What was she streaming?
I'm trying to figure out where the fuck the key is.
Just so... I am baby.
I am... I am fucking baby right now.
I don't know what...
I don't know...
I don't know where to go.
Look, there's a plane ticket.
I'm a baby on a fucking desk right now.
I'm stuck on this one level.
Baby doesn't know where to go, guys.
Check the drawers.
The drawers are like climbing things.
They're not like...
There's nothing in the drawers.
They're only used for... to climb.
I would know because I've climbed many, many drawers.
Thank you so much for the follow and sad boy.
Thank you, thank you.
Applebutter.
I hope you guys enjoyed Gumi's stream.
I hope you guys enjoyed her streams.
I was watching both streams until Gumi fell...
Did she like... was she playing in the middle of Among Us?
And then she fell asleep?
Right in the middle of the game?
Oh my god.
That's like...
Gumi.
Oh, that's pretty funny.
That's pretty funny.
I got a baby and I'm stuck on the...
Dude, I wanna be back.
I wanna be back in the...
I don't know where to go, guys.
Where do they want me to go?
I'm just a fucking baby.
Wait...
Where's Harold?
Hey, Zero.
She didn't fall asleep.
She just laid back and started watching Undertale Dog on her phone and forgot about the game.
Oh my god.
That's hilarious.
That's actually pretty funny.
I'm like stuck on this level because I have no idea where to go.
I don't know where the fuck to find the key.
Yeah, we hit our...
I'm gonna be back here until Harold passed me by.
Um... Hey, maybe Harold knows where the key is.
Let me go ask Harold real quick.
Okay.
Chat.
Alright, who wants a backseat game for me right now?
Any backseaters?
Chat?
I have no shame.
Any backseaters wanna come in and help me right now?
Please.
This is my one time.
I will allow backseat gaming.
Harold?
Paul, thank you so much for the follow.
I do appreciate it.
Have a... have a blood heart.
Thank you.
Are we supposed to go upstairs?
No, I... I need a key though.
I need a key to go upstairs.
I don't know where the key is.
Oh, wait.
Harold, I'm sorry, Harold.
Bye, Harold.
Hey, Harold.
Please, I'm stupid, Chat.
Please, you know I'm stupid.
Chat, you know I'm stupid.
Harold, do you know where the key is?
Thank you so much for the follow.
Hello, Vane, Origen, and Yen.
Thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Have a whole blood heart.
Thank you so much.
Hello, Fox.
Welcome, welcome.
Thanks, Harold.
Harold doesn't know, I guess.
I'm stupid.
Chat, I'm stupid.
I need all the help I can get.
I'm so stupid.
I'm sorry.
Harold doesn't know.
I don't know.
I've been stuck in this level for 20 years.
Hey, I'm back here.
Hey, welcome back.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Have a whole blood heart.
Thank you.
Okay, Chat.
So, I guess we just live here.
I guess we just live here.
Oh my god.
Okay, what happened to this chair?
How did I fuck up the chair?
How did I break the chair?
Okay, maybe.
Ghost and Shab, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have some blood hearts.
Thank you so much, guys.
Thank you, everyone.
So, yeah, I've been stuck in this particular level for 20 years.
Because I have no idea where the key is.
Well...
Okay.
That's outside.
Wait, wait.
Is the key up here?
Oh my god.
Okay, there's no... no, it's not.
I thought it was so fucking smart.
I honestly thought it was so fucking smart.
It's just pens.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, everyone, for the follows.
Alright, so...
I guess we're never gonna I guess we're gonna live here forever now.
Remember when I said this level only takes 15 minutes to complete?
Well, then...
No, I can get up.
I can open these doors to climb up.
Remember when I said this is a 15 minute level?
Well...
About that...
I...
Gumi is alive.
Did Gumi wake up?
Did she wake up, chat?
Alright, time...
Wait, look it up.
Liquid!
Oh god, is that him?
Is that Harold?
Liquid, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
Have a blood heart.
Thank you so much.
I really do appreciate it.
Well, then...
Um...
When is...
When is Gumi Pukimo one day be finished?
I just have so much stuff to do lately.
I've had a lot of shit to do.
So...
We haven't had time to actually...
actually...
work on it.
Where the fuck is the key, guys?
I hear it on other people's stream.
Oh shit!
You know what, I'm just gonna go back upstairs.
Maybe...
She'll never sleep with you.
I hope that good she was asleep.
Um...
Okay... Where the...
God, please!
Where's the key?
Where are you?
Let me in.
Harold?
Harold, I hear you.
Harold!
I hear you, Harold!
I don't wanna go downstairs cause I hear him!
Please...
Someone backseat game!
Someone be a hero!
The keys of friends we made along the way.
Oh god...
Harry, Harold, never enough.
I'll find you.
Oh, back here we go!
Hey guys!
Remember me?
Remember me, guys?
Oh, I'm back.
Wow!
Hey, I'm back here!
What's on the other side of the stairs?
The other side of the stairs is just, um...
Just toys.
There's no key down there.
Dude, we've been...
How long have we been stuck here?
Like, we went here...
We went here...
We went here already.
This is Harold.
This is where we...
Hey look, we're back here again.
Welcome back.
How many times have we been here, chat?
How many fucking times have we been here?
Oh my god.
No, we explored the entire house.
That's the thing.
Do I just go outside?
I'm sorry.
Wait...
That's a great...
Wait, this is locked too!
Why is everything locked?
That's a great...
Thank you, sis.
Why is everything locked?
Please!
I don't know what to do!
Who's that sound?
Oh!
Oh, that was me moving the shoes.
Right?
That's the shoes, right?
Not Harold?
Oh!
Harold, I'm sorry.
Harold.
I'm gonna go back in my happy area.
Oh, my god.
What is this?
I'm so fucking angry.
How do I finish this?
We've been stuck here for 20 years, chat.
Where is it?
Okay, we're gonna...
Alright, okay.
We got this.
Let me check all the rooms again.
Okay.
I'm checking everything.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, my god.
This is a fucking door.
This is a door!
It's a fucking door!
We're all stupid!
Let me in!
Baby, I'm...
All I had to do was go down!
Baby had to go down!
Light!
Wait, this is killing me?
Oh, this kills me.
Wait, what?
I just went towards the light!
It said light!
That is light!
Fire hot.
Okay, apparently fire is very hot.
Look.
Hey, look.
Thank god.
You know, okay, that makes sense.
Cause I was wondering, like, why am I freaked out about the heater?
And...
Yo, guys, do you guys know?
Fire is bad for babies?
Something I learned today.
Fire bad.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
You appreciate it.
Have a... have a fun heart.
Thank you so much.
I'll have my Amazon package here later cause I'm about to have fires at it.
Oof.
Oh my gosh.
Hey, today I learned that that fire is very bad for you.
Oh, please.
Oh, Rasty, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Have a fun heart.
Thank you.
That really sucks though.
That really fucking...
Oh, do I have to...
Fire.
Fire?
Fire!
Thank you.
Have a... have a fun heart.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Look, I didn't use my brain.
It took me 20 minutes to find...
find the stupid...
Dude, please.
I...
Oh, window.
Window.
I was like, what do you want me to do?
Pause!
Holy shit.
Thank you so much for the tier one.
41 month streak.
Woo!
That is... okay.
It's okay.
Fire is very far from me.
Woo!
Can we get some Bargnite real quick for Pulse?
Holy shit.
He was... he was super.
He was like my super OG.
OG, OG sub.
Viewer.
Okay, fire bad.
Fire bad.
Okay.
Alright.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Okay.
Hey there.
Alright.
How do I get up?
Do I have to move this box over?
It's okay.
Oh!
Woah!
Please!
I don't know how to get up there!
I'm running!
Oh my god!
Fire bad!
Okay, I got this.
Alright, I just need to slowly push this.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Okay.
I thought I could push it all the way.
What the fuck?
Wow!
What is that kill range?
He just gets third quarters.
Damn!
This is looking strong ass heater right here.
I'm sorry, heater.
I'm sorry.
I'm running.
Please.
Wait.
What the fuck?
The chair is... Wait, what the fuck?
The chair is back there.
Wait, what?
The chair is already back there.
Alright.
Yeah, you think I'm scared of you?
Turn radio on.
Equals happy.
Radio equals happy.
Yeah, that's right.
Get in my stomach.
Okay, now what do I do with this?
Wait, what do I...
Okay, I finished it.
Woo!
We finished!
The radio on the way equals happy?
Oh shit.
Shit, what did you order?
What did you get Felicity?
Okay, okay.
Okay, baby can't crawl apparently.
Now it's upstairs open.
It's upstairs open now?
What else does Anxiety have to resolve there?
Oh no!
You're okay Felicity.
What the fuck?
Harold?
Does the baby just go...
at me?
Oh, upstairs!
I didn't need a key after all!
I just had to go to the fucking basement!
Wait, what?
Do I need a key here?
Oh my gosh.
Hey guys!
Harold?
So why are we putting a visage?
Never.
Oh!
Oh, let me in!
Let me in!
I don't know how to close it.
I don't know how to close it!
Why is it open?
Please Harold.
Please don't come in Harold.
Harold don't come in!
I don't know how to close the doors apparently.
Baby dumb!
Baby stupid!
Oh fuck.
Hey don't come in.
Change it closer right now.
Oh god, baby needs to climb?
Why are you making baby climb?
Baby too stupid for that.
Baby dumb!
What the fuck?
Baby go up?
Wait what?
How do baby go up?
Up?
No chair for me.
Parkour!
Baby parkour apparently.
What the fuck is this stupid shit?
Baby parkour?
Parkour.
This game is a platformer right?
Are you?
Oh you dumb bitch!
You stupid dumb bunny.
I'm stupid.
Who can tell my baby?
What the fuck?
What am I watching?
We are watching baby right now.
You dumb bitch.
I'm falling out the window.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Harold?
Harold is that you?
Hey Harold.
What the fuck?
It just blocks me there?
Baby go bye bye.
Oh my god.
The donkey boy.
Let me out.
Let the baby out.
Baby out.
Baby leave.
Wait where the fuck is the doll?
Bye.
Baby go out.
He doesn't care anymore.
Baby is leaving.
Baby doesn't care anymore.
I think you just walked over it.
They actually just left the...
No he's here.
Look he's here.
Look at that.
What?
Oh mom.
Mom what the fuck?
Hey mom.
I don't want to look at all of this.
I don't want to look at mom.
It's too much.
No.
Mom no.
Where's Harold?
Holy shit the bunny.
Remember the hiding.
Oh shit ready to kill.
Oh my god.
Guys.
Remember how this was a...
So it was a 15 minute level.
Oh please.
How long did that take me?
Most of my memories are in the about moving.
What's the start from where I'm moving to?
How empty it was.
Oh no.
14 minutes?
Oh shit.
I broke a record guys.
It only took me 14 minutes to fucking figure out that it was a basement.
To figure out there was a fucking basement.
It took me 14 minutes.
Oh my god.
I'm so good at this game guys.
I can't believe.
It took us that fucking long.
To finish a 15 minute level.
Where's basement?
Alright.
I can't believe this.
Oh no Autumn.
Sorry.
Don't worry.
It was just me yelling we're baby.
We're key.
Don't worry Autumn.
It's 12 minutes.
20 minutes of that was just me shouting where the fuck's the key and going around.
And like walking around the house 20 times.